ils ont convergé de partout vider les
vestiaires de la contestation gilet
jaune
un père rouge blouses blanches que ni de
papier et plastron de cartons loin de
retourner leur veste et les portent
désormais en couches serré le grand
débat national ne peut ni se substituer
ni contourner encore moins être opposé
aux revendications sociales et
syndicales
c'était important de d'intégrer ce
mouvement qui finalement fait converger
les luttes les luttes syndicales qui
existe depuis très longtemps elle et
l'ust sociale des gilets jaunes portés
par les gilets jaunes et les ut les
luttes pour la santé de tous portés par
les blouses blanches santé éducation
finances service public au sens large
ont mis leur souffrance au pot commun
augmentation des salaires et pensions
retrait des lois busin blanc cayrel
conneries macron l'éventail des
revendications s'élargit de jour en jour
et grossit les cortèges et pas question
de se laisser museler
on est dans le plat france le pays des
droits de l'homme et on doit pas
accepter qu'on nous empêche de
manifester pour défendre nos conditions
sociales voilà le calme et le respect
comme on l'a toujours fait on est
pacifiste et ju on veut juste avancer
nos revendications sociales
une violence sociale terrible les
licenciements les gens qui peuvent plus
vivre qu'à un moment il faut qu'on soit
écouté c'est tout venant à tous à des
gilets et certains même qu'on pas de
gilet du tout
voilà et c'est comment on voit bien que
là tout le monde dénonce la même chose
le pouvoir d'achat les conditions de
travail qui se dégradent et ainsi de
suite et il va bien falloir qu'on se bat
tous ensemble sinon on va encore
continuer à se battre se battre
longtemps
du mardi au samedi la lutte des classes
déborde de plus en plus du calendrier un
grand malaise qui appelle plus qu'un
grand débat pour recoudre un tissu
social usé jusqu'à la trame